atravesando las aguas profundas estos
residentes de la ciudad sureña de sindh
ahora sin hogar salvan las pertenencias
que pueden no tenemos agua potable las
tuberías han sido destruidas un motor
eléctrico también está avería no queda
nada que pueda hacer mis hijos tienen
hambre y el sol es abrazado llevamos 4 o
5 días atrapados en el agua hemos
luchado por sobrevivir durante 4 o 5
días salimos de ese lío por nuestra
cuenta caminamos durante cuatro días
los desplazados por las inundaciones
arman refugios improvisados en cualquier
lugar seco que puedan encontrar a lo
largo de la carretera o buscan refugio
en campamentos abarrotados las
autoridades calculan que podrían tardar
cinco años en la reconstrucción de las
zonas afectadas con un coste altísimo
para el país asolado por la pobreza se
calcula que el 45 por ciento de los
cultivos de algodón han sido arrasados
además de los enormes daños sufridos en
la cosecha de hortalizas y en los campos
de fruta y arroz en rise and water para
más cuando enviamos bombas de agua nos
dicen que dónde bombeamos el agua todo
un gran océano no hay tierra firme para
bombear el agua así que se ha convertido
en una crisis de proporciones
inimaginables
proporciones
pakistán ha solicitado ayuda
internacional para hacer frente a las
abrumadoras inundaciones y algunos
países ya han enviado suministros y
equipos de rescate